one thing was interesting to me i'm
working on a column called the reason
they defend crime is because they're
against capitalism which is that when
you find people defending
um
the shoplifting the complete looting of
walgreens and you know the uh you know
drug stores in california because you
can steal as you mentioned 950 worth of
items without any consequence
the people who will defend that are
socialists who say well walgreens rips
off its workers
did you talk to any of the progressives
say in san francisco here in l.a who you
know like chesa bodine or george gascon
these da's who have decided not to
prosecute basic crimes so or even in new
york they're doing things like this if
you jump the turnstile they won't arrest
you so you're incentivizing people to
break the law but you know if you steal
i think it's under 899 dollars worth of
stuff at a store they basically won't
prosecute you so you could get a
playstation 5 and you get five games but
you take that six game and now you're in
trouble did you like now i get it i get
it they feel like they're helping
somebody who might need to steal a
carton of milk or something like that
not even that that would make it right
but do you ever get a better explanation
on stuff that we all see the videos and
we're like geez we know this is not
right
right so this is your what you're
describing is a selective view of
victims so progressives are really
concerned with victims of the system and
they're giving a pass to
victims of other individuals so to speak
so so you know give an example of it
progressives are very concerned with uh
people who they feel are being
victimized by police
than people who are being victimized by
other individuals so african americans
are killed at a rate 30 times higher by
other civilians than they are by the
police and yet there's a huge movement
around police killings which you know is
advocating some reforms that i think are
very positive and we should do but
there's basically no movement whatsoever
for reducing homicides
um among african americans more broadly
um what about uh drug addicts on the
street who are often stabbed with
machetes by drug dealers if they don't
you know pay what they owe them that's
how it gets enforced
um
there's just kind of a shrug into the
shoulders by progressives at those
crimes and the drug dealers according to
chesa bodine
most of whom are from honduras not all
but a lot of the and that's just
particularly san francisco but the
hondurans control the drug trade in san
francisco and chester boudin has said
that their victims the drug dealers are
victims of human trafficking
that's not true by the way but because
they're people of color and they're
immigrants they get put in the category
of victims so what i'm interested what i
was interested in was why the selected
the selective categorization of victims
and what you come up with is that is
that progressives are strictly concerned
with victims of the system and not
concerned with people that are
victimized by others and so you know one
thing was interesting to me i'm working
on a column called the reason they
defend crime is because they're against
capitalism which is that when you find
people defending
um
the shoplifting the complete looting of
walgreens and you know the uh you know
drug stores in california because you
can steal as you mentioned 950 worth of
items without any consequence the people
who will defend that are socialists who
say well walgreens rips off its workers
so what you find in the book in san
francis san francisco i document
a long history going back of course to
the 60s of antagonism
to the police but to the criminal
justice system more broadly
and this goes back really to
the 19th century radical anarchists and
socialists who viewed crime
as sort of justified
um because it was um you know getting
that you know fighting back against the
man
um and so so that that's where that
selective victimization comes from i i
felt the need to write san francisco
because i think when my soccer my
progressive soccer buddies read it and
you kind of lay out
where is this ideology coming from and
you realize that yeah it's really that
stupid
like it's like you know you get to the
bottom of it you're like wow that dumb
are you like i thought it maybe would be
more sophisticated but it's just that
stupid at bottom and it's still there
there
yeah once you make it explicit i think
it's harder for people to defend it
does it sort of impress you almost i
mean i ask almost all my guesses at this
point it's caused so much destruction
this radical ideology and destroyed so
many institutions literally destroyed
cities it's destroying colleges it's
destroying it's destroying basically the
fabric of american society do you
somehow admire it in some weird perverse
way i mean even in the last couple days
we're holding this interview for a few
days but in the last couple days you
know kirsten cinema got chased into that
bathroom at arizona state university and
i saw an incredible amount of
progressives and progressive news
organizations defending her oh yeah you
can get up in their face which by the
way is exactly what maxine waters has
been on the record saying get in their
face that you almost admire their
absolute relentless pursuit of
destruction
yeah i mean there's and there's a
cunning to it there's a cleverness to
the manipulation of language in
particular i mean just take a simple
word like homelessness i traced the you
know genealogy of this word back it's a
propaganda word um it's always been a
propaganda word designed
to mix together two ex totally different
groups of people one is the proverbial
mother escaping an abusive husband with
her two kids who doesn't have anywhere
to go that night
mixing her together with people
suffering from schizophrenia who are on
the streets often addicted to hard drugs
or people that are just addicted to hard
drugs mixing those populations together
deliberately confusing two groups of
people who require completely different
things and by the way we do a pretty
good job taking care of the mom escaping
the abusive husband she needs something
different than someone with
schizophrenia and that person
schizophrenia needs something different
than someone who's just addicted to
heroin but the word homelessness
suggests that the only response should
be a charitable response when sometimes
you do need to involve law enforcement
to either
make make sure the laws are enforced
and also to compel treatment because
it's not compassionate to let people die
from drug overdose on the street they
should i they you know look i don't want
to if someone wants to kill themselves
in the privacy of their own home fine
but we don't allow people to kill
themselves on the street that's not
that's not something that's consistent
with a civilized society so yeah i sort
of i can admire the cunning the
manipulation but there's just something
really sociopathic about all of it i
mean there's a there's a view
i heard a lot of people say things like
our unhoused population and it just gave
me the creeps dude like it was just like
they're not your population like they're
not they're not objects for you to
control these are often people that
you're contributing in their
victimization
out of some hatred of the system
so yeah it's scary dude um
i remember
i remember when i was lefty and they
would always say fam like we're fam and
i hated it because it was like you're
not my family like we may be friends or
a group and we all kind of have common
cause in some of this stuff but like you
also hate family like they hate the
family structure but we're fam because
we have some like ideological cohesion
or something like that
there's a lot of that forced they call
it forced teaming you know that sort of
sense that we're wrong conforming it's
also a lot of menace there if you don't
conform you'll be ostracized and
stigmatized and all the rest so as you
talk about this stuff and as you write
this stuff and go through whatever your
own political evolution is um
you know you're having a similar
experience to what happened with me
which is your i sense you're finding
that people on the right generally
aren't that bad you know you've done
some stuff with with prageru you know
scary dennis prager uh and i think
you've had conversations with ben
shapiro and a couple other people um
how's that been for you and have there
been red lines with those guys that
you've said something that was so
outlandish so crazily left that they
didn't want to talk to you anymore or
didn't want to air something or wanted
to censor something or silence you etc
no i mean that that's that is shocking
right which is that you know if you go
on a conservative tv show your
progressive friends it's just it's so
upsetting to them
that like the friendship is threatened
whereas if you go on a liberal show like
nobody on the right seems to care you
know and so
it's clearly you know i mean this is my
second book i'm writing a trilogy and
the books you know apocalypse never came
out last year san francisco is coming
out next tuesday
i've got a third book in the works and
these are books really about how these
threats to civilization and the
institutions that support civilization
are coming from people in the grip of a
religious fervor there's this is a
fanaticism and it's it's what's at stake
for you know for when you know like you
kind of like so you go on a show with
somebody you don't like like why would
that threaten like a friendship you know
why would that break up you know why
would that be such a threat to somebody
it's because they have so much of their
identities riding on their political
identity so much of themselves around
their political identity so that their
people's politics have become their new
gods new religions and so we're seeing
you know it's interesting because when
new religions form they are more
fanatical and more apocalyptic
then they become over time they start
more extreme so what's scary is that
this is a new you know is that this is a
new religion
that's asserting its control over the
society
we have to push back against it we have
to expose how harmful it is you know
part of the reason i wanted to write san
francisco was
it's not just the universities you know
that there's there's real victims of
these policies um 93 000 deaths last
year i'm not going to say all of them
are due to these policies but we went
from 17 000 20 years ago to 93 000 last
year that's a lot of dead bodies
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell